depuis son ouverture le 19 juillet le
musée du père pinchon attire chaque jour
150 à 200 visiteurs l'entrée est
gratuite pour tous jusqu'à nouvel ordre
le temps d'installer la grande
exposition permanente
le musée conserve dix mille pièces de la
collection du père pinchon moins de 40
ans après sa mort la plupart de ces
espèces ont aujourd'hui disparu ou sont
en danger d'extinction
il faut toujours parler des espèces
justement qui était endémique de la
martinique par exemple ici nous avons la
cour est ce qui est une une couleur qui
a disparu la martinique ce musée il est
là aussi pour sonner une alarme
personnelle
exactement on en est pas encore en
parler du glas d'accord mais au moins le
tocsin c'est à dire de secouer toutes
les personnes que ce soit les pouvoirs
publics les naturalistes les
scientifiques
et puis les amoureux de la nature pour
leur dire il faut absolument faire
quelque chose pour protéger ce qui nous
entoure oiseaux insectes reptiles
espèces marines menacées
les teams de la destruction de leur
habitat de la pollution et de l'excès de
produits chimiques dans nos jardins et
nos campagnes
ça a éveillé les consciences au niveau
des enfants des familles qui viennent et
ensuite j'espère que les écoles comme
c'est quand même un endroit qui est
récemment ouverts vont aussi
venir c'est intéressant surtout que le
père pinchon avant c'était un professeur
et ce musée je crois qu'on a est fait
pour lui nous enseigner personnellement
depuis la 6ème jusqu'à jusqu'à la
première l'histoire-géographie naissance
naturelle c'était un bonheur d'être avec
lui c'était plus nous inciter à regarder
à connaître il ya à prendre conscience
de ce qu'on avait une pas simone et
pourtant les inciter à le faire il ya
être très très vigilant là dessus
yahoo veut nous eu à observer
aujourd'hui la préservation de la faune
et de la flore intéresse beaucoup de nos
citoyens et fort heureusement le travail
d'inventaire se poursuit de nos jours
dans cet atelier
l'on apprend à constituer un herbier
comme le père pinchon enseignait à ses
élèves alors ça va être un beau timbre
et martinique a pour vocation finalement
abandonné en biais de l'effet russe qui
forcément donc pas besoin répertorier
toutes les espèces présentes
que ce soit les espèces autochtones
endémique et parmi celles-ci espèces
rares ou menacées forcément ans
aujourd'hui en faisant cette campagne
donc par le biais du musée du père
pinchon sensibilise la population aux
espèces en voie de disparition
le musée est ouvert de 8 heures à 17
heures jusqu'au samedi midi la grande
diversité de ses collections enfin
présenté au public
réveil de nombreux souvenirs
nostalgiques chez les anciens élèves du
professeur painchaud décédé en 1981